因为你赚赚赔赔赚赔赔赔赔
你可能在一次大赔之后
你就会觉得我好辛苦
我到底什么时候才赚得回来
他提醒我们说
你如果关注在期望值这件事情上面的时候
你就知道原来赔钱也是过程之一
只是如果这次赔的钱真的超过原本的规划的时候
我就可以去思考
我如何下一次交易的时候不要赔这么多钱
或是透过各种机制
让我这个风险锁在一定范围内
大家好 欢迎来到理财小时候理财读书会
很高兴今天国荣这边又要跟各位介绍好书
那今天想要跟各位介绍的一本好书是
天下文化所出版的《巨人思维》
这本书的上面的一个标题是
台股传奇交易员巨人杰
他的著作
因为时间点其实也过了一整年
今年2024年已经过了
行情交易也到这个位置
所以我们想说透过本书来帮助各位做一个盘点
来看看我们今年的交易状况
跟这些高手的思维到底有多大的落差
首先我想先来了解一下
巨人节在著作本书的时候他的一个初衷
这是我喜欢看书的时候去探讨的
因为看一本书的时候最要清楚的是
他本书想要跟你沟通什么样的理念
我们先稍微介绍一下巨人节的一个背景
因为毕竟这位交易员应该是
如果不写这本书的话
大部分人是不认识他的
他是1993年出生的
他其实还蛮年轻的
他是出生背景是算是小康家庭
父母都是当老师的
那他本身是中原大学应用数学系
跟最后是政治大学统计研究所毕业的
这个很有趣
那他的一个交易的成果
就是我们常的股市常听到的所谓的少年帮
就是很多年轻人
在所谓的航海王
或者是在今年比特币
或者是等等的一个市场上
赚到大钱的一些传奇故事
他自己的一些很好的交易经验
写成这本书的时候
我稍微看过了一遍之后
我就知道说
这个交易员其实真的
他不是靠幸运得来的
他真的是一步一脚印
扎扎实实的去堆叠出
他的一个交易经验
因为他17岁才开始进入这个市场
他自己说
他本身在市场上的研究
曾经疯狂的时候
是一天只睡5个小时
因为他大部分的时间
就是不睡觉时间的17个小时
基本上都用在做研究跟做交易
这个书上的一个横标上面就写
他很有自信
我一定会赔钱
但是他也很自信说
我赔的钱都是值得的
也就是说他里面的每一笔交易
都是他未来获利的一个
所谓的很好的经验跟数据
可以让他去再掌握下次获利的机会
我们来看一下他本身
这本书的核心理念
他想要透过这本书
帮助所有的投资人去建立一个心态
以及对于风险不对称的一个观念
还有他在商品转换的时候的一个经验
透过这本书就是让
如果你是新手的话
你可以透过他的人生经验跟过程
还有他对股市的观察
去了解一下这个市场的全貌
当然我们不敢说是全貌
至少是一个
从一个成功交易员的一个过往的经验
还有观察去看看
这个市场到底是长什么样子的
所以他也说这本书
不是有什么样的神奇的成功密集
你不会看了这本书就会赚钱
你也不会说因为看了这本书
就会财富自由而不用工作
他是希望说你看完这本书之后
你会放弃所谓靠价差交易
然后交易自负
因为这一条路真的不是很好走
他并不是说不会达到
而是不容易
如果你看完之后你就觉得
你没有这样的一个心智的话
某种程度他先劝退
不要玩这个游戏了
因为你必须要把他当事业来做
你才有机会跟他一样
作者他认为他自己有现代的成果
不是靠天赋得来的
而是他靠了十几年
长期的研究跟努力所得出来的成果
因为大部分人在年轻的时候
高中大学的阶段可能都在玩游戏
但是他就是热衷于研究跟投资
还有做交易
所以他认为他得来的这份成果
是绝对是扎扎实实的
他很自信说
我所说出来的
我所写出来的内容
是非常有价值的
我们当然就是说
一般券商都为了要吸引人
来进入这个市场
都会找到一些赢家
来分享他们的交易经验
各位可以看到
很多券商都一定会办很多的
赢家分享会
缺点就是过度简化
没办法
因为在短短的几十分钟内
那些所谓的seminar
或者是一些分享会
他只能很片段的告诉你
他的成功经验
但是我们没办法去体验这整个过程
所以总以为
我如果照着那些方法
或者是一些观念跟态度
我就有机会成为赢家
因为大部分都是抱着雄心壮志
就是有为者亦弱士
我想要进到市场
成为跟他们一样的一个
成功交易员
日进抖金
每天都赚个一二十万
但是最后都是沮丧的离开市场
90%以上
可能都是这样的一个结果
所以作者他一开始在书中
也有讲到说
那为什么他整个成功过程中
没有像大家所想象这么的戏剧化
因为在出这本书的时候
出版社当然是希望说
他寫一些比較戲劇化的故事
就像傑西里弗摩
以前股師作手回憶力的作者
他還是會經歷所謂的兩三次的破產
或者像川普這個王者歸來多麼戲劇性公私破產然後選總統第一次還敗選還衝撞國會等等
到現在敗部歸來
這麼樣有戲劇性的內容
但是作者巨人姐就說了
他其實整個過程是非常扎實的前進
為什麼 因為他的家教
這個是我必須要再各位提醒的
做事要多研究
架構好之後再去行動
這個就是他老爸的一個提醒
他老爸本身是個老師
他小時候也跟大家一樣
家庭教育就是希望你多去嘗試
多才多應
所以彈過鋼琴
他身高也是很高的
可能190幾
他就想像說我這樣的漢超
我這樣的身材要去彈鋼琴
這能看嗎
所以他小時候
也經歷過很多的才藝的訓練班
但是都没有找到一个方向
但最后他父母就给他了一笔钱
让他去开户
他也很感谢父母
真的有带他去开户
他最后在市场上得到成果
父母也给他一个很开放的路线
让他多方尝试
我不知道各位父母
有没有心智
或者是觉得说
股市投资是一条不归路
或者是赌博
因为他父母居然可以让他
在这么小的年纪
就是高中的时候就去开个户
来试试看怎么样去做
交易跟投资
所以我对于他父亲的教诲
做事前要多研究架构好之后再去做
所以是一个培养一个很谨慎的态度
让他进入市场上的时候
并不是非常照进的
因为很多人来股市希望的就是赚快钱
希望赶快得到身价
比如说30岁
我就要身价千万百万
从股市落到很多钱
但是這樣的一個加訊
幫助他在扎實的一個電基礎的過程中
能夠實現這樣子穩扎穩打的一個過程
這也讓我想到以前我在做金融研究的時候
雖然我爸爸媽媽沒有這樣給我一個加訊
但是我那時候就想到五周制藥的理念
這邊幫他打個小廣告
因為五周制藥理念是先研究不傷身
再講究效果
这就是我在以前在做金融投资的时候
为什么也没有受过什么大伤
相对保守
保守原因是因为我对很多东西要思考说
怎么样做才不会重伤
因为我们在业界其实经历了很多的故事
也看到很多人如何输钱
所以都知道说每个交易策略都有它的弱点
弱项
我如果要长长秋秋在这市场上存活
我一定要思考说
我什么样的做法
才不会让我中断交易
就像前几本书
不管是致富心态也好
或是一如既往
里面所谈到的一些观念
就像复利效应那些事情
你不能中断
你要在存股的过程中
你要也要思考
我怎么样定期定额存ETF
我不会中断
你才有办法看到那个效果
在做金融交易的时候
也应当如此
因为90%的教育院投资人
可能在两三年就会退出市场
过一阵子才会有新的
所谓的散户进场
所以才会被戏称为韭菜
就是割完一波
很快就涨新的一波出来
你如果要摆脱所谓的韭菜的命运
各位就可以参考这一个教诲
做事前要多研究
先架构好之后再去行动
虽然这样会有点慢
但是你会在行进的过程中
比较扎实一点
那我觉得自负心态里面有一个重要的观念
就是说不要为了增加1%的获利而忽略
其背后带来风险成本
为什么我一在开张名义的时候
会跟各位多强化这个观念
风险跟利润的关系
里面提到说专职交易员
因为他已经是把他当工作的人了
专职交易员就是不靠领薪水过日子
全部只靠金融交易在过生活的人
就如同许多创业追梦者一样
他打拼的过程中
一样会遇到许多酸甜苦辣的人
是过程跟经验
唯有经历过的人才能够体会
他过程中也是不断的失败跟尝试
也是一样会经历过心魔的拉扯
否定自己是不是要再继续走这条路
所以这个都是他的整个路程中
跟一般人没有差别
看这本书就要让你知道说
为何他能够度过那个阶段
接下来我们就可以看看
他在看待交易这件事情的
一些重要观念
因为本身也是做交易出身的
因为我做过研究员
然后也经历过
代课操作的一个生涯
我这边稍微看一下
他几个重要的观念
我觉得值得提的
也可以让大家去思索
你在做金融交易的时候
你要focus的是什么
那居然姐他本身
他最强烈的建议是说
与其你每天在看
你今天赚几十万赔几十万
或者是几百万几千万
你应该要更加专注
如何去突破你的期望值
期望值这个数学公式
其实他主要的观念就是说
你当你赚钱的时候
可以赚多少
比如说你每一次的交易
可以赚个一万块
但是你要去统计
你这样的交易的几率
有多高
比如说出手100次
你也没办法赚到60次
再来第二个就是要加上
你亏损的时候
你要付出的成本
比如说亏损
你每次决定要退出市场的时候
你是亏多少
比如说50万
100万
然后这样发生的几率是多少
你总和过后
你要专注的就是
这条上面数据的4个向线
获利金额
亏损的金额
以及獲利的機率跟虧損的機率
雖然這次100%去對等去計算的
成功的交易員
他們關注的是在這件事情上面
因為從這邊去出發的時候
你就不會一直在care說
我金額大小的問題
你就會提升這整個4個數字的拉抬
然後最後這樣子你就會簡單告訴你說如果你算出來了每日的期望值是30万你就可以去预期你未来500个交易日之后对不对
你就有1.5亿的一个收益
这就是你可以预期到
你就心里相对笃定一点
否则的话
你就会在过程中会很多的痛苦
你就不知道说
我到底的努力的方向是什么
因为你转转赔赔赔赔赔赔
你可能在一次大赔之后
你就会觉得我好辛苦
我到底什么时候才赚得回来
他提醒我们说
你如果关注在期望值
这件事情上面的时候
你就知道原来赔钱
也是过程之一
只是如果这次赔的钱
真的超过原本的规划的时候
我就可以去思考
我如何下一次交易的时候
不要赔这么多钱
或是透过各种机制
让我这个风险锁在一定范围内
比如说你一开始
如果你真的砍股票
你砍不下手
对不对
你買台積電比如說100萬跌到50萬
你砍不下手
那你就要思考
我如果要控制在一次交易只能賠10萬的話
那我的建議就是
你只能最多買台積電20萬
因為他有可能腰斬
有可能腰斬
那你至少在20萬的範圍內
你可以繼續運作
當然這是每個人自己去思考
你如何控制最大損失的一個方法
然後你要更加了解自己
为何行动上面无法持续跟进行的原因
里面有几个有趣的观点
我想说这边跟各位提到一下
比如说我们常讲说市场上有主力
主力都会坑蒙拐骗
我们这边养套杀
所以他就想其实主力要拉抬一只股票
也不简单
他要去造势
他要去吸纳筹码
甚至他过程中要不断的去制造
所谓的有利的形态
让散户愿意参与
大家就可以去类比
很多的诈骗的前期过程
他必须要去养各位
养各位就是要培养信任度
培养信任度的过程
就是说你在投资股票上面
他一定要让你去熟悉一个pattern
不管是他报的名牌很准
或者是技术上的形态
让你很好切入跟赚到钱
或者是他放出来的新闻跟消息
让你觉得可以得到印证
而你慢慢去相信这家公司是可以涨到1000块
类似这样子
主力在拉抬股票其实也是不容易的
我们只是说要更清楚说
原来主力在操作股票这件事情
我们要避免不要被洗进去
第二个是现在市场上有ETF很热门
ETF的游戏规则反而是新形态的主力出货的观察重点
我会拉出来看是因为
近期我們的ETF市場非常熱絡
如果我們不知道
我們只是長期投資
我們就要想想看
有些ETF是不是有一定的風險
比如說配期型的ETF
配期型的ETF
它只要遊戲規則很明確
主力就知道說
我如何讓這支股票
進入到這檔ETF的標的物裡面
它就有機會去做財報
或者是去创造有利的条件
让这支ETF选进去
他选进去之后
就可以知道说有多少买盘
会进来去买这支股票
他就可以很轻松的
把股票倒给各位散户
这个就是我想要讲的
一个重要的观点
如果当热门ETF拉高的时候
因为我们过往
在没有ETF没那么盛行的时候
过往的经验就是磨台子
它是由经由台湾100党的股票所组成的
那里面也有它的选股机制
所谓国外的一些投资人
他们可能都会关注
什么时候某些公司会被剔除
什么时候某些公司会被加入
他们有自己的判断机制
所以他们去研究的是
这个机制哪些公司股票会被选入
或者哪些公司股票会被剔除
他们就会去及早布局跟放空
当然一定有胜率的问题
就像刚刚居然姐讲的
他们关注的是所谓的期望值
所以它里面重点是几率
那个几率
提醒各位投资人或是教育员
这样的一个现象
是不是要值得各位去更加小心
当指数变动的时候
成分股变动的时候
很多主力会在这边做一个调整
另外一个想要在这边跟各位谈论的
就是我们常听到的就是技术分析
因为我们刚进市场的时候
你如果不是本身科班出身
会有兴趣去研究财务报表
或是你不是财务跟会计出身的
那就研究基本面这块
应该不是各位初始入世的时候
会去学习的
一般券商也会教各位一些
所谓的简单的判断法则
通常都是基于筹码面跟技术面
或是设计一些技术指标
让大家去参考
里面我觉得有趣的是
他如何运用的过程
他说他以前刚开始学技术分析的时候
他说他也会看
但是那个时候他就是看
他怎么去搭配指标
所以KD指标出现买讯
MACD也出现所谓的多头讯号
他就会在KD指标买讯的时候介入
我是举例
他那个时候就会以所谓的技术
技术指标的买卖点去当优先考虑的
等他交易了一阵经验之后
发现说这个真的不太看
技术指标都落后指标
我现在已经不太看指标
我都会看量价关系
老手就看量价
因为这才是市场上最快反应的指标
K线怎么走
成交量怎么出现
才会跟你判断说
现在市场到底要不要冲出去
但是以他现阶段的角度
交易十几年他会看
但是他是因为
他没有办法去记住
每一支公司股票的走势
所以他用技術指标去快速记忆
记忆说现在股票什么会接
什么位置
会不会过热等等的
他是用这个方式来看整体市场的表现所以技术分析变成是他跟市场沟通共识的工具跟语言工具跟语言不代表它是背后真的会怎么样
只是说你可以透过这个工具
知道说现在市场是不是过了
现在市场是不是一个可以买进的点位
或者是市场现在走到什么阶段了
就像以前我们看一个投机者告白
可是Toranin他也没有学很多技术分析
他只会看M投跟Labority
他看筹码部分
他就有自己的所谓的弹型理论
去判断说
现在犹豫的投资者
跟固执的投资者
哪边比较多
就像巴菲特
他有自己的一个衡量指标
所以他根本就是反市场
他现在现金部位那么庞大
跟我们自己的理解跟逻辑
又不太一样
因为我最近看了一些投资论坛
很多的研究机构都告诉我们说
这三年最好的投资标的物就是股票
可是巴菲特居然持有大量的现金
所以必然跟很多投资机构的
判断因子都不太一样
所以这些老手在看
这些量化的数据的时候
其实都只是在判断一些
跟他自己的市场共识
就是他自己的判断跟市场共识
是不是有接近一致
后来他也没有在追求技术分析
因为其实我们当初学技术分析
就是看到说
买卖点怎么那么明确
我是不是想象说
我如果学了很多技术分析之后
我可能就找到获利的胜碑
就像城市交易
他们赚到城市交易回撤之后
看到很棒的一个财务报表
因为城市交易
他会告诉你说
你如果透过这个机制去做
你一年可以赚到几倍
或是几十%
你就会发现说
原来打败巴菲特是做多么容易的事情
这你就会好像打了鸡血一样
疯狂的学技术分析
或是学写城市交易
那里面
后来为什么他不太追求
因为后来本来想追求圣杯的心态放下了
因为他慢慢认识
原来影响股价的因子太多太复杂
你根本无法完全掌控
这就在上一集
我们在讲一如既往的时候
也有提到了一些观念
你根本没有办法做预测
过往的历史经验在一如既往这本书
就是我们上一集在讲一如既往的时候
有提到历史经济学家
他已经告诉你
他在研究历史的一些预测上面
发现没有一个人可以准确预期到
未来怎么发展
如果你有这样的一个观念跟看法之后
你就知道说预期不是重点
这些预期当然可以有
但你不要去那么的
笃信他一定会发生
作者他在讲的
他不太关注所谓的准确度
他关注的是他的期望值
就是他赚的时候能不能多赚一点
赔的时候能不能少赔一点
然后让赚钱的几率提高一点
这样就可以了
所以说他知道说这些东西
不是他关心的重点
就是他放下之后
另外就是要讲到说
所谓的风险报酬不对称的观念
大家为什么要建立这个观念
因为他跟人生的决策很有关系
比如说为什么很多年轻人想要创业
虽然成功率非常低
但是你越年轻去创业的时候
要面对的损失也是最小的
你可能当时你创业的时间跟成本
都不会比你工作了一二十年之后
累积了一笔资金
然后你突然要出完创业
那个要承担的风险小很多
所以在做任何决策的时候
都要考虑了说我胜率多高
然后我如果失败了
我可不可以承受得起
所以這個是在所謂的風險不對稱的關係裡面
需要找投資機會的時候都要去這樣思考
當然我們一樣要impress到
這副心態裡面就講了
風險都是永遠存在的
一樣會連結到清源油那一段
所謂的負值的交易
一樣很多人都會看到說
我最大的損失已經非常小了
我想說我在地板接近您的時候
去買進一口期貨
我就有機會爆賺
大家就要去思考一下
原来还有是隐形看不见的风险
大家如何去规避和选择工具很重要
就像大乐透一样有这样概念
一小博大
但是它几率就是真的很小
好 这一集我想就先暂时停在这边
我们下一集的时候会去好好地探讨一下
里面它的一个成长过程
就是它从菜鸟成为一个
成功交易赢家的各种阶段
这本巨人思维我觉得最大的价值
就在于他已经有深刻的交易经验
再回过头来用心的将很多生活的实证
用很多我们听得懂的大白话去跟我们沟通
因为我发现说很多的交易员
要嘛就是文笔太好
但是没有真正的成功经验
但是这位成功的交易员
是市场认证的
因为他交易经济真的是很大
而且是在这个圈子里面
可能待久一点都认识的
所以他愿意用心在这边琢磨这些文字
他自己就承认
他觉得这本书卖的价格
跟他所投注的经历跟用心
是不成对等的
所以各位就可以好好的先买这本书
在即将过年的期间
好好去透过本书的内容
去好好的盘点一下
过往的交易
不管你是成功或者是失败
至少才一年的经验
这边有十几年的一个交易经验的总结
让各位去好好的反省
我相信这边一定可以得到很多宝贵的经验
今天理财小时候读书会就先暂停在这边
希望我们下一次再讨论
他的新书的另外一个阶段
就是他如何从菜鸟成为一个成功交易员
我们看看能不能从他的成功经验里面
得到更多宝贵的一些交易经验
好
感谢各位今天的参与
谢谢